Let's talk about the l word today.
No,
not that l word,
the other l word liberal.
I've always considered myself a liberal
probably before I even knew what the
word actually meant as a kid.
I remember thinking that liberals were
the good guys.
Liberals were looking out for other
people.
Liberals wanted a fair society and
liberals didn't care about race or
religion.
Before I go any further,
you guys know I love definitions,
so let's actually define the word
liberal according to the Oxford
Dictionary,
one,
open to new behavior or opinions and
willing to discard traditional values to
concerned mainly with broadening a
person's general knowledge and
experience rather than with technical or
professional training.
All right.
Being open to new opinions and
broadening your knowledge.
Both seem like good ideas,
right?
With these two definitions in mind,
you can understand why liberals have
been on the forefront of the civil
rights movement,
workers' rights,
women's rights,
and marriage equality.
Sometimes to get everyone to a place of
equality,
you have to throw out the societal norms
and be willing to accept a new normal.
Conservatives often argue that change
isn't good or at least change that comes
to fastest and I think in certain cases
there can be some truth to that
mentality,
but if you're the black person sitting
in the back of the bus or a woman trying
to vote or the gay person who can't get
married,
change can't happen soon enough.
I mentioned all of this because I don't
want to lose my credit as a real liberal
since I've had some conservative guests
on the Rubin report.
I've seen people suddenly calling me or
conservative or claiming that I'm a
Republican.
As I've mentioned before,
I've never voted for a Republican for
any major office,
so if I'm a Republican,
I'm a pretty bad one.
Just because I talked to Ben Shapiro or
Milo Yiannopoulos or your own Brooke of
the Iron Rand Institute doesn't mean I
share any or all of their beliefs and
that's exactly the same as when I talked
to left leading guests like Jimmy Dore,
Riva Martin,
or my guest this week.
John Fugelsang saying,
I listened to people push back when I
see fit and see where the conversation
goes.
I know some of you want me to
electrocute my guests every time they
say saying I disagree with,
but there is a litany of legal reasons.
We just can't do that,
but beyond the legal reasons.
I'm a firm believer that good ideas
always beat out bad ideas.
If you let the light shine on both of
them,
it's not liberal or even decent to shout
down or silence ideas just because you
don't like them.
That has been and always will be the
driving force behind the Rubin report.
I view liberal thinking and liberal
ideas as generally good over the past
few months as I've explored classical
liberalism with its focus on civil
liberties and economic freedom.
I've come to realize in many cases,
liberal ideas aren't that far from
libertarian ideas.
You can make excellent arguments for
racial equality,
gender equality,
and marriage equality,
all from both liberal and Libertarian
points of view.
The main difference is how you think the
role of government should be applied.
In any of those cases,
a liberal may want marriage equality
because they believed that a gay couple
deserves to be treated the same as a
straight couple.
A libertarian may want marriage equality
because they don't believe the
government has the right to tell any two
people what kind of contract they can
partake in.
The silent majority of us have much more
in common than we have apart,
especially if you're a moderate on
either side or just a good old fashioned
centrist.
I tend to think that most of you who
watched the Rubin report fall somewhere
on that spectrum.
I don't pretend to have every answer
because it's preposterous to do so.
Unfortunately,
not having an answer doesn't stop most
talking heads.
I prefer to analyze each situation with
the same level of critical thinking that
I apply to the rest of my life.
Unfortunately,
many liberals have taken a turn into
stifling descent with cries of racism
and bigotry.
Every time they hear an idea that they
don't like.
To me being liberal is a constant
evolution of ideas.
As time goes on.
This concept doesn't mean changing my
ideals or my morals from day to day,
but it means that I can change as the
world changes.
I see the world in shades of gray rather
than black and white.
The world is constantly changing and I'm
not ashamed to admit that my opinions
have changed along with it.
That isn't the position of a man without
conviction.
It's a position of a man with a
conscience.
As liberals,
we must be brave enough to have our
ideas challenge just like we challenge
the ideas that came before us.
At the end of the day,
this isn't about right and wrong.
It's about having the bravery to defend
your ideals.
So to my liberal friends who have chosen
censorship over ideas and smearing over
debate,
I challenge you to be brave.
If our ideas are good and our causes,
just we shouldn't be afraid to defend
them.
John Fugal saying is a comedian host of
tell me everything on Sirius xm insight
and a good buddy of mine,
John,
it took a while,
but we've got you on the show.
Thank you very much,
David.
It's a pleasure to be back on your show.
We really should have recorded what
happened for these last six or eight
minutes because we had.
I think it's pretty good for your
viewers.
You didn't record what just happened.
We had a little miscommunication whether
we were doing this at 11:30
AM or pm.
Long story short,
we just followed you as you ran across
the Sirius xm hallway with your laptop
screaming like a crazy person.
Uh,
well,
the good news is my evening is now free.
I thought we were taping.
I thought you were taping at 5:30
PM your time.
Uh,
so 8:30
PM your time.
So I apologize for the,
uh,
for the uh,
a grasp of the details.
But,
um,
my defense is that I went to public
school.
Thank you.
I'm bringing you on to defend
liberalism,
to defend the left and we've already had
a time problem which has set us up here.
But first let.
Before we get into anything.
So you are at Sirius Xm.
That's where your show is.
You actually tape your show out of my
old studio,
is that correct?
Oh No,
it's not.
When I first met you,
it was a very different studio and I was
doing it from.
They just moved us to another one and
they're remodeling or here so many
times.
I have done a pre taped interviews in
your old studio and I always think of
you and I always scour the room for
narcotics you might've lived.
Do you dedicate each show to me?
I hope so.
In my heart.
I do.
Days in my heart.
Alright,
well let's get to it here because you
are one of my favorite comics.
You're actually one of the only guys
that can drag me to do standup.
Pretty much the only time I do stand up
these days is when you say,
all right,
I'm in town and I'm doing one of my
shows and you do these great comedy
nation shows that are mostly about
politics and free speech and religion.
I mean,
all the things that I like talking
about.
Uh,
so before we get into comedy,
let's just talk about your history
because you have an incredible
upbringing.
Your parents background.
Go fugal sang one.
Oh,
let's go.
mine.
We're where to begin at the beginning.
Uh,
I'm,
I'm an actor.
I'm a stand up.
I'm a broadcaster.
I've,
uh,
I,
I come from a curiously Catholic
background.
My parents are both a former Catholic
clergy members.
My father being a Franciscan brother,
my mother being a nun who spent many
years as a nurse working with lepers in
the jungles of Malawi,
Africa.
Um,
with a background like that,
I could never afford the therapy I
actually needed.
So I got into theater and stand up and
uh,
over the course of my career I've,
I've hosted adult literacy shows for
pbs.
I have a,
I've been murdered on CSI.
Um,
I've gotten drama league nominations for
off Broadway Solo shows.
I worked on MSNBC,
Fox News and CNN.
I hosted my own program for the late
limited current channel.
I once got mid,
run these advisor to call ms and etch a
sketch,
got George Harrison to play his final,
uh,
on camera performance.
And I hosted America's funniest home
videos with daisy puentes.
So yeah,
it's a pretty schizophrenia resume.
That's kind of,
not many people can say they replaced
Bob Saget,
but you did.
Oh,
I could never replace Bob Saget.
Even his wife agreed with that.
Um,
but I,
I was happy to,
uh,
to,
to take over for the show for a little,
it was only going to be for like six
weeks and it wound up being a year and a
half,
so it was a fun little Gig and it taught
me that,
um,
that wasn't what I needed to do.
Yeah.
So I like doing a little bit of the
pedigree stuff because it's important to
know,
you know,
I feel like there's so many talking
heads and nobody knows what their
backgrounds are,
what they studied,
where they came from,
and it's uh,
it's nice knowing that.
So this religious upbringing that you
had,
when did you sort of realize,
as you said you couldn't afford therapy,
so you went into acting and comedy.
When did you realize that maybe some of
the constructs of religion word for you?
That's a great question because I think
that we,
you know,
one that we don't talk about too much is
the separation of church and faith.
Um,
the fact that religion and belief are
two completely different things and a
religion is a culture of middleman,
whereas faith is just a between the
believer and the day the,
of their choice.
Um,
you know,
I,
I always had problems with religion even
when I was about.
And uh,
it wasn't until I went to college and
Nyu at the Nyu Catholic Center and uh,
it was very progressive community.
I was actually asked to help teach a,
uh,
a course for Congress along with the
pastor and it was a church that welcomed
gay people openly.
And I remember bringing my parents to,
uh,
to the church I went to in college and
they were so inspired by seeing how gay
couples were welcomed and loved.
This isn't the ABS.
Um,
and uh,
that Kinda made me realize,
well,
that's not the usual policy for this
unauthorized fan club with Jesus.
You know,
the more I was really when I saw my dad
gave a lecture at a college once about
Martin Luther and the reformation,
that I was like,
why are we Catholic?
Why aren't we Lutheran?
These rolled in critiques.
You have the pope,
and so that was what really made me be
a,
not a Catholic.
I still consider the Catholic church to
be my asexual sexual orientation.
But,
um,
over the years,
uh,
I found the farther I got away from
organized religion,
the more interested in theology and
faith I got.
And so,
uh,
now I get to La and a everybody because
the snf of them think I'm a,
I'm a,
I'm a cult member.
So you're making a really interesting
distinction there.
So you're not into organized religion as
it stands,
but you are a believer,
correct?
Yeah,
I'm a believer.
Sure.
Uh,
um,
but I don't think God's an invisible man
with a beard and a penis in the sky,
but there was no lightening bolts when
he's in a moody situation.
You read the Old Testament.
It's like the alcoholic step God.
Um,
and it's like this big gut cosmic game
of candid camera and God's Allen funt.
Um,
so yeah,
I,
I make a distinction.
I was asked to go and come out bell show
and debate Jamie Kilstein about,
uh,
atheism versus belief.
And I was like,
well,
I'll never tell an atheist they are
wrong.
My definition of faith doesn't involve
telling other people that they're wrong.
Um,
when I got into the studio they wanted
me to,
to defend religion.
And I'm like,
no,
no.
I like,
I'll defend anyone's right to worship.
And as long as you're not bothering
anybody else's personal property,
you're putting somebody down in the name
of Jesus then good for you.
God bless.
Find the fan club that works for you.
But,
uh,
I'm not going to defend religion.
I'm going to descend to faith and
belief.
Um,
and they were like,
well,
no,
don't do that.
Just,
just,
just as I said,
I'm sorry I can't.
And so Jamie and I just told jokes and
it got a million hits on Youtube.
Um,
because I think people are really tired
of the whole.
My God can beat up your God thing.
Uh,
some of the best Christians I know are
atheists,
some of the most godless and,
and even atheists can go crazy.
You know,
I mean,
there's fundamentalist atheists.
I love the atheist handbook a,
it's a great set of rules for people who
are tired of religions set of rules.
For me,
it's like,
you know,
my faith is such that you believe what
you want to believe if it makes you a
better person.
I'm the Dalai Lama says the purpose of
religion is to,
uh,
the purpose of religion is to improve
yourself,
not criticize others.
And uh,
that's kind of where I come from.
Although I do enjoy mocking hypocrites.
Right?
And that's been my thing.
Yeah.
You love mocking hypocrites and that's a
lot about,
you know,
what you're about and when I see you
going back and forth with people on
twitter,
a hypocrisy.
And that's the main thing usually that
comedians call out.
So when it comes to faith,
so your faith is just your faith to you.
I sense it's just something private.
You don't if you're not even defining
what your faith is really,
right?
No,
I'm not.
I mean,
if anyone wants to talk to me about it,
I will.
But generally,
I,
my faith is such that I don't pretend to
know all the answers and they often say
the opposite of faith is doubt.
I think that's rubbish.
I think doubt is an integral part of
faith.
The opposite of faith is certainty.
And I trust anybody who,
who's searching for the truth.
I generally don't trust people who claim
they here.
Right.
So it's interesting because me and you
were sort of splitting hairs on this.
I would say I'm not a believer.
I wouldn't believe in something without
evidence.
But that said,
I don't mind.
I know a lot of,
a lot of atheists don't like,
people don't like religious people or
think that they're really just diluted
or whatever it is.
And to me,
I would go with sort of what you just
said,
which is I don't mind if someone's
religious,
uh,
because I won't pretend to be more moral
than anyone or,
or living somehow a better life than
anyone else.
I just don't want them pushing it on me
or hitting me or put throw in gaze off
roofs.
Yeah.
I don't want them using their personal
faith as an excuse to put somebody else
down,
and that's something I take very
seriously.
There is no part of the Bible you can
ever use to justify discrimination
against lgbt people.
And I have this debate not infrequently.
Again,
there's no part of the Bible.
Anyone can honestly use to justify any
sort of discrimination.
And,
and when you're starting to use Jesus,
when you're starting to use Christianity
as a cloaking device for Douche baggery,
that's what I have to call you out.
Again,
I've known wonderful conservative
religious people.
I think that very often conservative
Christians can be more liberal with
kindness.
Then lots of liberals,
you'll find a lot more liberality of
warmth and love,
uh,
at certain,
you know,
baptist meetings,
then you'll find it upper east side
cocktail parties.
So,
um,
but,
but for me,
I'm in love with a mystery.
Yeah.
And,
and my definition of God does not
involve a man with a penis.
And,
um,
you know,
I think that the Bible,
uh,
the main character,
the Bible,
Jesus is a guy who spoke in parable and
metaphor.
I don't know why it's so hard to read
the Bible as parable metaphor.
Uh,
there's a lot of truth in the Bible.
Not necessarily a lot of facts.
Yeah.
Alright.
I feel good about our start here.
We sort of see this a little bit
differently,
but I respect where you're coming from
and that sort of what both of us.
Yeah.
I just want to be vague enough to sucker
people.
Yeah.
No,
you're quite good at it.
And by wearing all black and with the
long hair,
it's the whole thing is very effective.
Thank you very much.
I've got a beautiful compound that I
want to invite all of your viewers down.
You'll have to turn over some account
numbers and were rogues,
but it's a really a great safe
community.
I think you'll love what we do there.
Yeah.
Well we'll put the link in the
description down below.
Don't worry about that.
Um,
okay.
So let's,
let's shift a little bit to comedy
before we jump right into politics.
So,
uh,
when did you really decide,
okay,
I've got something to say and people
need to hear it because that's like,
that's a crazy thing for a person to do.
And I say that as someone that has done
standup for a long time.
Well,
I don't know if anyone needs to hear
anything.
I do.
I never really felt that.
I just knew that.
Um,
the first time I saw George Carlin lies,
he made me feel less alone and uh,
and I knew I wanted to do what he did.
I want it to come out and,
and rail against injustice and,
and,
and nonsense and lies.
Uh,
but I,
I didn't want to just be a propagandist.
I wanted to do it creatively.
I wanted to find ways to be funny and,
uh,
and make it entertaining.
And I've always tried to adhere to a
principle of entertaining first and
formative.
Second,
seconded preachy last,
um,
which is easier on stage than it is on
twitter,
I'm sure.
But I've always,
uh,
Carlin was really good for me.
I was a fan of his before I saw him
live,
but once I saw him lives,
uh,
I,
I knew that that's what I wanted to do
and um,
I so admired how he went after
politicians and religious leaders and
um,
and just creeps in general and did it
using humor,
um,
rather than hate or a or just propaganda
and um,
so for me,
I love doing stand up.
It's just silly nonsense.
But I also,
I also really love to,
uh,
to work out logic through,
um,
penis jokes.
That's my morality.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
to me the real beauty of Carlin was that
key was the most political you could
possibly be.
And yet at the same time,
very rarely commented on politics of the
day,
you know what I mean?
Like right now,
if he was alive,
I don't think he would be commenting
that much on the race horse that we're
all caught in of the trump,
hillary,
Bernie,
this,
that,
the other thing.
But he would be commenting on the bigger
pieces of it and then you Kinda,
you kinda take the same approach.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I mean,
you know,
he,
he spoke extensively about the Reagan
administration.
Uh,
he,
he talks a lot about Clinton versus
double.
I mean if you listen to the albums from
the eighties,
so what am I doing in New Jersey?
And then of course I think I'm a jam in
a jam and in New York is his best album
and back in town,
the one that followed it is almost as
good.
I think he would have flipped it up the
two,
but even like you are all diseased with
an album where he talked about Bush and,
and um,
you know,
he,
he talked a lot about,
uh,
supporting governor Bush after nine
slash 11,
you know,
he didn't like him.
He would only call him governor Bush.
I mean,
Carlin,
he didn't make us whole sets about it,
but he,
he more or less took on the introduced
bag in all of us and politicians were
very often the starting point for him to
jump off into,
into just social hypocrisy that the
politicians are just figureheads of.
So,
um,
he,
he did single out and,
and Clinton,
he went off on a lot.
I once saw him in Vegas where he was
railing against the Bush family and just
said,
I hope the whole family dies and an
airplane fire and people were walking
out in droves,
but it was a pleasure to watch him work
out as material that way and separate
the anger from the humor,
separate anger from the outrage because
anger doesn't work in comedy but
outraged us.
Right?
You got to get right to that line and
tow it properly,
and then you can tell some people the
truth because if you tell them the truth
and you're being funny,
that's good,
but if you tell them the truth and
you're not,
that's when the pitchforks come.
Yeah,
I think so.
I mean,
Billy Wilder,
Saturday,
Billy Wilder said,
if you're going to tell people the
truth,
make it funny or they'll kill you,
and I,
I keep that quote around.
Yeah,
there you go.
All right,
so let's,
let's jump into some political stuff.
You are a through and through liberal.
You're,
you're one of my left friends that I
still understand a lot of what I've been
doing on the show.
I've lost a lot of my people on the
left,
but I consider you a good liberal.
Do you consider yourself a liberal?
Does that have any meaning to you
anymore?
That the words.
I don't know what you're telling you the
truth.
I mean,
10 years ago I got called a liberal
because I supported gay marriage.
I supported a decriminalizing marijuana.
I thought Bush,
his economic plans weren't going to work
and I was against the Iraq war.
Uh,
it turns out I wasn't a liberal.
I was prematurely mainstream.
Right?
And throughout history,
I think prematurely mainstream is what
liberals have them.
They've been the ones who fight for
social change generally,
but you know,
everyone I know every interesting person
I know is liberal in some areas and
conservative and others,
uh,
if you're all just one or the other
thing,
it doesn't mean anything.
You become a guy at a star trek
convention.
So I,
I,
I get asked this question and I,
I don't really know what liberal means
anymore,
but when I read the dictionary
definition of the word I aspire to be
that,
you know,
like I was on the show on Fox News and
they kept trying to get me to admit I
was a liberal than I said I aspire to be
a liberal the same way I aspired to be a
Christian.
I don't know if I would ever self
identify as either of those two words.
Yeah,
well I love that.
And you weren't connected to us on skype
when I did the intro to the show,
but I actually took the deck,
the literal definition,
the dictionary definition of liberal and
I read it out and it's someone who's
basically,
if your ideas are evolving,
if you're willing to challenge the
status quo then then you are a liberal.
And it's so funny to me.
I remember back in 1992 when I was 12
years old and we were doing a mock
election when Dukakis was running
against George H,
w Bush and George was that.
I'm sorry,
that was 88,
that was 88.
Ninety two was the,
was a Clinton.
Uh,
and uh,
and George Hw said,
you're a liberal and Dukakis,
that I'm not a liberal.
And that was the Democrat because
liberal became a dirty word back then.
Yeah,
you're crazy for that.
By the end of that campaign,
Congress finally said,
yes,
I'm a liberal tradition of JFK and all
that.
And Bush celebrated instead of wonder of
wonders,
he finally admits it.
And I give Bush credit for,
uh,
making a word that means a empathetic
and open minded and caring about the
least of us.
A,
a word that pretty much sums up Jesus.
If you go by the dictionary definition,
uh,
and,
and Bush Sr,
I think it's the most credit for turning
it into a dirty word.
Uh,
you know,
I mean,
there's no way you can see that Jesus
wasn't a liberal if you go by the
dictionary definition of the term and he
certainly,
you know,
they,
they didn't,
uh,
the state didn't put them to death and
the conservative religious bosses of
their day didn't put him to death
because he didn't rock the boat up.
He didn't not want change,
right?
This is a guy who wanted some change.
Exactly.
But by that same token,
you know,
that that definition you bring up,
it's the greatest proof that we don't
have a liberal media.
Uh,
our friends on the right or thunder
saying it's the liberal media.
And I've just been like,
well,
this year is proven.
If the media was liberal,
I mean for awhile we've known if they
were liberal,
they'd probably cover an anti war rally
as much as they cover a tea party event.
Um,
but if the media was liberal,
I think they would have given Bernie
sanders a bit more than one 80th.
The air time they've given Donald Trump
the media profit driven.
There are a lot of liberals who work in
the media,
but the media itself is ratings driven.
It's profit driven.
That's not necessarily a bad thing.
That's just how it is.
And a lot of liberals and conservatives
can admit that.
Right?
So I love that you made that point
because yes,
it's profit driven and people want
clicks and people want views.
We all understand that.
I don't know what a better model would
be.
I don't know that the government coming
in and saying everyone should have
exactly equal time.
I don't know that that really makes
sense.
I'm not a huge government guy,
so I don't really love that.
And at the end of the day,
if more people are watching trump and
he's just using the system,
it's kind of Shitty,
but it's sort of where we're at.
Like what else?
What else can we do?
Like the restorative fairness doctrine,
we could have more than one pbs and we
can have a pvs for liberals and a pbs
for conservatives.
I think we could have presidential
debates every week on pbs where it's not
about profit,
uh,
present,
a corporate media from having to be
responsible to their shareholders.
That's just how the culture in the
industry has evolved.
Once you can admit that,
you know,
Donald Trump seems to think that all
these ratings and all this airtime mean
people love him with trump.
And I think a lot of folks in the media
haven't realized is a lot of these
ratings that trump generates is because
a large number of people are actually
hate watching him.
Uh,
he is the true detective season two of
politics and watching to see how
horrible he is.
The way you slow down for a car wreck,
um,
I don't think necessarily translates
into loves.
I stopped watching true detective season
two after one episode.
Unfortunately,
the country hasn't quite caught up to me
on that.
I stayed to the bitter end like Kennedy
Vice and let me tell,
you know,
I'll never get those 10 hours back.
But,
um,
you know,
I do think that,
that,
uh,
MSNBC is doing great in their ratings
now.
But I think it maybe because people are
just fascinated at this trump thing is
actually happening.
I mean,
as a novelty act historically,
it's never happened before.
It'll probably never happen again.
And uh,
so in that sense,
I think it's newsworthy in much the same
way.
I think the Malaysian plane going
missing or the Oj case was newsworthy.
These are things that have never
happened before.
Really be grudge the population for
leaning in to watch a,
a spectacle that our grandparents
couldn't have imagined.
Yeah.
So isn't it a little bit of both with
trump though,
because there's obviously the spectacle
and the sort of carnival atmosphere and
all that,
but at the same time I read the other
day that I think at this point he has
more votes than any other Republican in
the primaries,
or at least he's going to certainly
break a Romney's record or george w
Bush's record by the time California
runs around.
I think it's more than Reagan already.
Now.
Part of that is just demographics change
and all that kinda stuff.
But the point is that people are
actually.
People are actually voting for him.
It's not just you thing
one percent now a approval of the gop.
That means Dave,
that Donald trump is so popular,
he's got 50 percent of 28 percent of the
American Legion,
right?
Hillary and Bernie combined,
uh,
have gotten more votes.
Trump.
So if you were,
if you were conservative,
if you were a republican right now and
you were in a trump guy,
what would you do?
Because I find that they're in a real
bind right now because if you're a
mainstream establishment Republican,
I don't think you can go into that
convention and say,
we're going to steal this thing away
because we don't like it.
It would,
it would expose such a horrible flaw in
the system and really be undemocratic
and at the same time they're giving up
their party,
but I think they've already been exposed
that,
I mean,
I don't believe the Republican Party is
against the government at all.
Government is how in my lifetime they've
redistributed wealth to the top two
percent.
They don't dislike government.
They disliked democracy.
And we've seen it time and time again.
Look at these,
look at these ridiculous voter Id laws
that,
uh,
as soon as the supreme court removed the
preclearance regulations in 2013,
these voter ID laws go up all over the
place because they want as low a turnout
as possible.
We know they don't care about the will
of the people based on a Bush v Gore.
We know that they don't care about
democracy.
Um,
the government,
they're not really against that.
Yeah.
Where you before,
just like a basic voter id registration
thing,
just that you just have to have some
level of identification,
some government issued identification
because I get you on that,
but I don't think you should just be
able to walk in with nothing and just
sign.
If you've registered,
your name is on a,
is on a registry when you go into vote.
Right?
But shouldn't you have to prove that you
are that person?
Sure.
And votes in your place,
you know,
the fact is you're going to say that
this is a right,
unless you get a photo id and many of
these photo ids,
you have to pay fees to get.
So in reality,
that's a poll tax,
and so you know,
a lot of folks say that gutting the
voting rights act in 2013,
which was done by the way,
the same week,
they greenlit Sharknado too,
like that was just the end of our
country and my total coincidence,
but you know,
it doesn't just keep African Americans
from voting,
it was designed to keep seniors,
low income people of all races and
college kids from voting.
There's districts in this country where
you can vote with an NRA id but not a
university id.
And the right wing response to that is,
well yeah,
but foreigners can get college ids will
guess skeeter,
but foreigners can't have registered to
vote.
So that's not a problem where people are
killed by televisions every year that
are than vote illegally.
The New York Times did an extensive
study and found that out over a billion
votes cast far less than one percent
were fraudulent cast.
There's voter registration fraud.
There's no voter fraud is designed
deliberately to make people vote less.
Right.
I would say there's gotta be some way
that it can be subsidized.
So just give everyone some card that
proves who they are even even,
even if the numbers are incredibly low
and then you register and then you have
some card that has your picture on it
and the government paid for it and
that's it.
Your a voter registration card every
year to your home address.
But you know,
for me it's like this,
this whole thing with the voter id laws
is just more proof of how a undemocratic
the entire process is.
And I really think that what we should
be talking about,
how to make it easier to vote not
harder.
Why?
Why do we only vote the first Tuesday in
November?
Well,
it's because we're still living by 18th
century standards in an agrarian
economy.
We were mostly farmers and you were
planting your crops up until,
you know you are harvesting up until the
end of October.
And then the presumption was the first
Sunday in November you'd go to church
and then Monday it would take you
wonderful day traveling by horse or mule
to get to the nearest polling station.
And then you could vote on Tuesday.
So we're being controlled by the living
habits of people who've been dead for
over 100 years instead of having it be
like motor voter where you get your
registration as soon as you get your
license.
Uh,
why can't we have a holiday to vote?
That to me is the number one one.
Take the day off.
Yeah.
We're,
we're able to vote online.
I mean,
we should make it a lot easier.
We should be trying everything we can do
to drive up,
go to a enrollments to drive a voter
participation.
How people manage their own democracy.
Uh,
but since the beginning of this country,
when the founding fathers thought only
land owning white men should be allowed
to vote.
We've always talked the talk.
We haven't walked the walk.
And so I'm a big fan of democracy.
Yeah.
Democracy is good.
I will,
uh,
I will agree with you on that one.
All right,
so let's talk about the Democrats a
little bit,
I suspect,
but I can't totally confirm your.
You're a Bernie,
right?
I'm a Bernie guy.
Yeah.
Uh,
just if you go by policies alone,
but I mean,
no,
no candidates ever gonna,
you know,
we have these purity tests for our
politicians and no politician,
no a lover,
no relative,
no artist is ever gonna match your
entire checklist.
I mean,
every rockstar you've ever admired has
released a bad album or done something
embarrassing.
You know,
every great filmmaker hasn't,
beloved.
No politician is going to match your
purity tests at all.
And I see the Democratic Party,
which I'm not a member of.
I'm independent.
I always have been.
I'm not a democrat.
Republicans generally forced me to vote
that way,
but,
uh,
I,
I see the civil war where it's like,
you know,
mom's friends fighting with GRANDPA's
friend said,
it's so ugly.
I don't want to watch Margaret that
should or beat up fiveish finkel in a
cage match.
Just civil war of the left is the most
depressing thing about,
uh,
generally depressing election year.
And,
um,
you know,
I,
I have a lot of issues with Hillary
Clinton,
uh,
but I,
I don't really think that I'm ready to
hand the nuclear launch codes over to
Donald Trump just yet.
Right.
So let's unpack that a little bit
because I'm fully on board that,
that one of my problems with the left
right now is they have gone out of their
way to demonize hillary to a point that
they're making it sound like she is a
Neil Kahn.
That she wants to build nations and
fight all these extra words.
Now I get it.
She did vote for her act.
She did vote for the Iraq war.
She was secretary of state when,
when Ben Gazi happened,
but Barack Obama was president Barack
Obama's president.
Right now we're,
we have some troops now in Syria.
We have Afghanistan.
Sorry,
constant.
The most disgusting thing they've got.
I mean,
exploiting the murder of these four
people.
I'm pretty sure that it was terrorists
who did it,
but we've seen this whole process of how
can we take these corpses and use them
against politicians.
We don't.
Like first it was Susan Rice,
then it was Barack Obama,
now it's all Hillary Clinton's fault.
These folks have never blamed a
terrorist.
They've never held the CIA or portray
Patraeus responsible for what happened
there.
And we're never going to know because
most likely,
I mean Petraeus is mit resending to
speech that there was a black site
prison in the basement of that
constantly.
So we're never going to know the whole
story.
Uh,
you know,
for me,
I find half my day is spent defending
Hillary Clinton against unfair attacks.
I think blaming a woman for her
husband's infidelity.
Good luck getting female voters with
that.
I mean,
I hear people bringing up Bill Clinton
raped 20 to broderick again.
Well,
this has nothing to do with policy and
Bill Clinton is not running,
but Donald Trump has been accused of
rape.
Ronald Reagan was accused of rape.
Bill Clinton was accused of rape.
What are we going to do?
So this goes to that purity thing that
you mentioned because it seems to me
that the far left has taken Bernie.
And they've basically said,
Bernie's are Jesus.
We love all of these ideas.
And at the same time,
we love them so much that we have to
destroy Hillary.
And what I see the problem there is,
is that ultimately you could end up
ushering in president trump.
Absolutely.
Because the left will be,
they've demonized her to the point that
all these young people are just not
going to vote.
Right?
Yeah.
I'm voting
for new ones.
I think,
you know,
like,
I don't blame Ralph Nader for George
Bush becoming president of.
I thought it was great that Nader ran
and I think he had a right to run that.
I think that he had the best,
um,
policy position of any candidate that
year.
I do blame 90,000
idiots in Florida who knew they were in
a battle ground state and voted for
Nader.
Anyway.
So yeah,
I'm voting for nuance.
I like Bernie a lot on paper,
but the,
the magic number of this campaign date
is 147.
That's Ruth Bader Ginsburg's age this
year.
You're voting for the supreme court
possibly voting for three judges on the
Supreme Court.
Would you rather have Hillary Clinton
appoint someone who respects women's
reproductive freedoms or would you
rather have Donald Trump but Amarosa or
Gary Busey on the court?
This is what we're looking at right
here.
And so,
um,
I think that,
uh,
what's probably gonna wind up happening
is Hillary Clinton will get a lot of
people's votes.
She won't get their enthusiasm.
Well,
that seems pretty obvious.
I mean,
even the way you're describing,
not that you're saying you're supporting
her,
but even the way you're talking about
it's sort of just like,
it's like a tepid defense,
right?
You keep saying,
I bought my shows.
Tepid is the new black,
you know,
again,
it's like,
it's like I think that there's a lot of
folks who,
uh,
don't like hillary personally or don't
like her policies.
And I get all of that.
I will say that if she means half of
what you said on this election trail,
uh,
the 2016,
Hillary is a much better candidate than
the 2008.
Hillary,
I've been very,
very impressed with the positions and I
give 'em Bernie Sanders a ton of credit
for forcing her to take these moral
positions that would actually help the
middle class and help our economy.
I think Elizabeth Warren gets a lot of
credit to.
It's clear.
Uh,
Secretary Clinton has read Senator
Warren's book.
Um,
but I have a lot of issues with Hillary.
And let me tell you,
I,
I posted a couple of jokes defending her
against these,
a sexist attacks against her because of
her husband's and fidelity,
which I think is that one of the easiest
things you can do and the amount of
progressive.
So we came after me over it is
dispiriting because,
uh,
you know,
I don't consider Monica Lewinsky to be a
victim.
I think what Bill Clinton did was wrong
and unprofessional and I think he's paid
a deep price for it.
And um,
but I don't consider Monica Lewinsky to
be a victim and a,
and by having that point of view,
because it wasn't consensual
relationship between two adults by her
own testimony,
she pursued it.
And uh,
you know,
and I happen to think that I'm,
none of that is our business anyway,
but when you start trying to use a
woman's husband's infidelities against
her to say that she is unfit to serve
because she kept her marriage together
and didn't leave.
I don't know what their marriages.
I don't know what their arrangement is.
And I don't judge anybody in this life
for what system of love works for them.
If they both have their own people on
the side,
they're staying together.
Fine.
It's so hard to make a relationship work
in this world.
So hard to make love work in this world.
Hillary Clinton has been married,
I believe a one slash third.
The Times Donald trump has been married.
I don't get to judge someone's
relationship or how they loved.
Okay.
It's all a sham.
Marriage is fine.
It works for them.
Whatever I'm going to go based on the
issues and not based on someone's
personal life,
man.
Fugal saying,
I gotta tell you,
it is so refreshing to talk to someone
on the left with a little nuance because
this is what I've been talking about for
months that it seems to me the left has
lost their mind.
Everyone,
every time that you disagree with sort
of the mainstream progressives,
you are a racist or you are a beginner
or you are a homophobe and they've made
good,
decent people that are basically liberal
or basically centrist or even a little
conservative.
They've made them all look crazy and
that is fueling trump.
So this is the exact conversation I've
wanted to have with someone that I
consider a simpatico on this stuff.
One of the reasons why I've never joined
a political party because people just
lose their damn minds over this.
And I look at facebook,
which has just become like,
it's become like electronic Bosnia and
everyone's at war with everyone.
I kind of feel like y'all are going to
have to get along and share this earth
with each other after November of this
year.
And um,
so I don't want to really be a part of
the hate or the rancor and by that same
token,
I'll defend Donald Trump too.
I mean,
I'm,
I find myself defending people I don't
support who were unfairly attacked more
than anything.
Uh,
and it's,
it's really depressing,
but it kind of shows how we got where we
are.
By that same token,
the very fact that Bernie Sanders can go
this far in the campaign,
I mean he packed in 20,000
in a stadium in California,
in Sacramento last night with 10,000
outside.
Of course the media didn't cover this,
but the very fact that a,
a Jewish self-described democratic
socialists can do that well in this day
and age shows the power of the Internet
and online social media.
And it shows how far we've come as a
people.
I mean the,
the strides lgbt people have made in my
lifetime from when I was a teenager
living in New York in the eighties and
seeing the beginning of aids activism to
a sitting president,
Dorsey marriage equality during a heated
reelection battle.
That's why I still believe in the
American dream because I've seen people,
not politicians,
but people make this kind of change
happen.
Yeah.
And you know,
it's funny because right where you were
probably 10 feet from you or when I had
my show on Sirius Xm,
I think it was the first time we had met
or maybe we did stand up one or two
times together,
but you came on my show and we were
talking about marriage equality and you
were laying out such a good case for it,
but it was four years before it happened
and it seemed sort of edgy.
We're now,
it seems the norm and that's what
liberalism is supposed to be.
Sure.
I mean,
look,
it was liberals in the Republican Party
who ended slavery,
right?
I mean it was,
you know,
liberals in both parties who fought for
civil rights.
It was conservative.
So both parties who fought against the
civil rights movement,
uh,
you know,
it,
it's,
it's messy.
And like I said at the beginning of this
conversation,
I think we're all progressive in some
ways and conservative and other ways
that billy's most sane people.
I know,
um,
so,
you know,
I've seen a lot to be inspired by in my
life and uh,
I try to remind myself that I am a
recovering cynic and I don't ever want
to go back to being so dark again and
I'm catching a lot of heat for it
because,
you know,
in talking about Donald trump who is not
a conservative Republican,
he's just not,
he's a horrible human being.
But if you would ever told me,
Dave Rubin,
if you had ever told me that there'd be
a guy on stage at a Republican
presidential debate saying that Bush
lied us into war,
saying that planned parenthood does a
lot of good things for,
for women saying that,
um,
that hedge fund managers and
billionaires like himself,
it should be taxed more.
I,
I wouldn't have believed it.
I mean,
grover norquist is clutching his pearls
at.
And a lot of this.
But again,
the third right did the same thing.
And I think anyone who compares people
to Nazis is worse than Hitler.
But I will say a third,
right rose to power by,
uh,
by running against the Weimar republic.
And promising so many conservatives and
so many liberals,
whatever they wanted,
that people just kinda got caught up in
the emotion of it and this feeling of
national pride.
That's not to compare the Obama
administration to the Weimar Republic.
They're much more confident,
but the parallels are really,
really similar because Donald trump has
promised as much good progressive stuff
as he's promised.
Conservative stuff.
So talking about trump and sort of
running on emotion and not policy and
kind of giving everybody everything they
want and being to the left of what most
conservatives are yet still winning the
republican primaries and all that.
You had an interesting moment that you
touched on right at the top of the
etch-a-sketch sketch moment of the Mitt
Romney campaign where basically you were
on CNN and you questioned,
was it Romney's campaign manager?
Who Was it?
Communications director,
Eric,
for instance.
Okay.
And basically you said to him,
you know,
you guys have been saying all this bad
stuff about each other and the
Republican primaries and how do you move
forward.
That was sort of the gist of it.
And he said,
well,
it's an etch a sketch,
right?
And you can just sort of forget all that
stuff.
And reset.
Do you want to clean up the mess that I
created for you there?
No,
you got it.
I mean,
it was,
it was pretty.
It was a bit sneaky on my part because
I,
I knew that I wanted to ask a question
that I hadn't heard asked before.
And at the time everyone was saying,
is Mitt Romney Conservative enough?
That was the,
that was where all the mainstream media
was going.
You've got Gingrich and Santorum.
Is Mitt Romney really conservative
enough because main,
most mainstream media will never stop
chasing Fox News as audience.
And uh,
and my whole thing was,
isn't Mitt Romney to conservative?
Has any,
has any painted himself into an
ideological quarter in this campaign by,
you know,
it was easier to run against mccain in
2000.
Nowadays these guys in 2008,
uh,
um,
starting in 2008 now in 2012,
you know,
you're up against Gingrich and Santorum.
You're trying to be something you're
not.
And it's the same problem that every
Republican nominee is going to have for
quite a while when the tea party is
controlled,
when you're nominating process,
um,
it's sort of like the gop is gonna have
a tough time getting non lunatics
nominated for president.
Democrats have a different problem.
Nobody shows up to vote in midterms.
So both parties are kind of screwed.
And that's why we're looking at
potentially a generation of democratic
presidents and Republican congresses.
But,
you know,
I.
So I asked it in a,
in a very wordy,
newsy bs kind of way.
Um,
and to my shock,
he came out and said,
oh no,
you get to the midterm,
you get to the general.
And it,
it's,
it's like a reset button.
It's like an intro sketch.
And I couldn't believe it.
He had just admitted that Mitt Romney
had the ideology of the guy from a Mento
lift,
like a crack house mattress.
He changed positions like a,
like a,
like a yoga teacher,
untainted meth.
And um,
I,
I went home after the taping.
I was doing mornings every day on CNN.
And by that afternoon,
uh,
the clip had been shown everywhere I was
sitting in a cafe with my wife and baby
and that I saw myself on tv,
uh,
everyone began running it.
It was on the daily show and cold beer
that night and all the big networks and
I was getting calls from Europe and just
get sales went up,
I believe 16,000
percent on Amazon that night.
You get a cut of that.
I did not get a cut of that,
but I was asked to sign lots of veggies,
sketches for the next two years at every
one of my tour dates.
And,
um,
I guess I was proud to be a minor
historical footnote,
but you know,
it,
it is the sort of thing that Republican
voters in the Democratic voters as well
need to be weary of,
especially in a season when so many
don't trust trump or hillary.
Right?
So basically what you did with that
question was you pulled the mask off of
the endless bullshit because you
basically said to him,
you had to say some stuff to get through
and look at the Democrats have the same
problem.
I get you with the Republicans and the
tea party,
they dragged them to the right.
I think the Democrats have the same
problem now where they're being led by
the far left and that goes to the point
where we were talking about with
Hillary,
where they are going to demonize her and
then depressed.
They're actual people from from showing
up.
So I think both parties have this
problem,
but you expose this thing and it seems
like four years later trump has just
blown the whole thing apart.
Like there is no more a,
we have to pretend we're this or that.
Trump is just like I say whatever I
want,
you all love it and I'm just going to
keep doing it.
Even if I change my position every week.
Yeah.
And he will continue to change
positions.
He's already done it this week.
I'm not so sure that Bernie has led the
whole Party to the far left,
so I kinda think Bush and Cheney push
the country a lot more left to tell you
the truth and I don't think Bernie
Sanders has sent anything too
outrageous.
He's really advocating for things that
have worked in other countries that are
our capitalist allies and for things
that have worked here in the past under
President Eisenhower.
Well,
interestingly,
I don't think that Bernie necessarily is
leading it,
but I think that that movement that's
behind him is leading him in a way that
I don't know that he fully grasps.
I think that some of the social justice
stuff and just the,
the behavior of the far left is not
behavior that he uses.
I tweeted once,
I wish that I liked Bernie supporters as
much as I like Bernie.
I think he is a pretty decent guy,
but I think he's being led by the.
By.
I go ahead.
I don't know if he's being led.
I think his campaign is being tainted by
some of his followers,
but that's fair circumstances here.
Number one,
we have no idea how of these online
trolls are actually republicans
pretending to be Bernie supporters
because I do wound hillary.
Mom tells mom,
always said,
don't talk to strange eggs,
are right,
talk to any eggs with 20 followers
because they're trolls and you know,
there's whoever owns them as a whole
basket.
Uh,
also,
you know,
a lot of these same situations apply to
Hillary Clinton supporters as well.
There is uncommon hostility towards
Bernie supporters from tons of Hillary
supporters.
And the generational divide in Hillary
Clinton's campaign has been fascinating.
You know,
there've been studies showing that women
over 45 have waited their whole life for
a woman president and they've worked for
this and they need,
they really want this to happen.
And I respect that.
But the same studies show that women
under 45 know that in their lifetime
there will be a woman president and
they'd all go for Elizabeth Warren in a
second.
Uh,
they don't totally trust this woman
candidate.
So it,
it's,
it's a real reckoning that,
uh,
our country is going to have to face.
I kind of am inclined to believe day
that whoever gets the job is going to be
a one term punching bag because I don't
know who could enact a kind of sweeping
reform.
We need to actually restore the middle
class.
We're sort of in the golden age of
gradual improvement.
That's hailed as sweeping reform.
I think Bernie Sanders was smart.
If I was advising them,
I would tell them to take a one term
pledge and then just say that once he
got in there,
he was just going to executive order us
into having a middleclass again and then
leave.
I think it's the smartest thing you
could do what trump is,
but when you be okay with that,
really,
uh,
the executive branch getting more and
more power because almost every
president at this point takes more power
for that branch.
And even if you think about the emphasis
that we put on the presidential
election,
there are only a third of the
government,
right?
But we barely ever talk about,
uh,
the Senate and the Congress,
right?
We barely talked about the supreme
court.
So the idea of giving the president more
power,
do you fear that because somebody that
you didn't like it then get into office
and you wouldn't be happy about it,
right?
Argument for reform,
you know what I mean?
All the Democrats who were demanding
that Harry Reid and the Filibuster,
uh,
you know,
when the Democrats had to send it now,
so grateful they didn't because it gives
the Democrats some leverage.
We've never had this level of
obstruction before.
And congressional history.
Bill Clinton broke the record for the
most filibusters against the president
in US history.
He had more than every other president
combined.
And under Obama,
it's already tops.
Clinton in Obama's first term and top
Clinton.
So this isn't,
I'm not talking about big government.
I'm talking about good government and
you know,
I,
I know that things move slow.
Things are designed to move slow.
But I just spent a couple of years of my
life working on a film for pbs about the
American dream.
We retraced Alexis de Tocqueville's
journey in 18,
31 and interviewed over 200 people in 55
cities in 17 states.
About what the American dream was and
what it is now,
and it's one thing for me to sit in a
radio or a TV studio and be lofty about
this,
but actually having good on the road for
a couple of years.
The American dream is not what it once
was.
We were raised to believe that we were
in a country where you could work hard,
play by the rules,
and you would prosper and your children
could know that they were going to have
a higher standard of living than you.
After 35 years of deregulation,
of outsourcing,
of Deindustrialization,
of automation,
of jobs being shipped away that are
never coming back.
That's not the American dream anymore.
It's gone from prosperity to survival
for millions.
Retirement doesn't exist anymore.
The middle class is now just the top of
the bottom and it doesn't have to be
this way and if policies got us here,
policies could get us out of here,
but I fear we being the slow learning
monkeys that we are going to have to get
a lot worse before it gets better.
Yeah.
That's been a theme that I've talked to
a lot of people about that a lot of
people that I really respect and like
are saying that it's going to get worse
before it gets better and everything you
just described,
whether you are on the left or the
right,
it explains both Bernie and trump
because it's about people are voting or
at least expressing themselves about the
broken system,
not the policies.
That's why it doesn't matter what trump
says.
He's just saying something and for the
Bernie people,
it doesn't matter whether the president
actually has the authority to do these
things and change the banking system the
way he wants to and all of this stuff
and the minimum wage thing,
which the president can't just do with a
pen.
Essential Kennedy talking about it as a
platform for position.
So it's just,
you know,
if you go for that,
it's the American people saying that's
what we want,
but we know.
We know that the government doesn't care
about democracy.
Go back to Obama.
Look what the American people voted for
twice.
Closing Gitmo.
The American people voted for a public
option.
The American people voted for higher
taxes on the wealthy.
Obama had to wait until he was elected
twice before he could just restore tax
codes to Clinton levels.
Uh,
you know,
they,
they run on these things.
And then of course,
once they were an officer not allowed
to.
And I'm like,
well,
what about the will of the voters so
that,
that does come into it.
In the case of trump,
it's fascinating because he's proved
once and for all that nobody hates
Republican politicians more than
Republican primary voters.
Right?
And there's something sort of beautiful
about that.
That's why I'm conflicted about the
whole thing because it's like,
I don't like the idea of this person
that I don't know really what he
believes in and is using the media in
such a crass and sort of dishonest way.
And then at the same time,
all of these leaders,
I wasn't a fan of any of the mainstream
Republicans beforehand.
So watching them all kind of crumble and
watching all the talking heads on all
the cable news networks,
watching the same people who got
everything wrong six months ago now.
Now they're afraid.
Right?
You can see fear in them.
When I watched them,
I watched them on CNN and I go,
wow,
you can tell they're afraid for their
jobs now because they've all been
phoning it in for years for the system
and now they're afraid.
Wow,
this guy can come in,
we can be out of a Gig.
Exactly.
Watching the Republican races,
like watching Batman v Superman,
I don't know who I'm rooting for.
I just wanted to be done.
And uh,
and,
you know,
in that sense it's revealed a lot of
the,
uh,
the discontented.
We,
we can't forget that the first ever
third party president got into the White
House with only 38 percent of the vote
and he was a republican and it was
Lincoln and the two party do wobbly is
what a lot of people don't trust.
And you know,
maybe trump could have done better if
he'd run as a,
as a,
uh,
a third party independent.
Although he did that before,
I believe,
and you know,
didn't get anywhere with it,
but,
you know,
that was before he became a reality TV
star.
Um,
it,
it's interesting.
I guess if I was advising the Republican
Party,
I,
I think the smartest thing we've heard
comes from William Kristol,
which I'm kind of liberal,
are you have broken clocks that are
right more than him.
The fact is William Kristol is leading
this consortium of Republicans trying to
persuade a mainstream well known
Republican leader who's out of the game
to make a third party run.
Their fear is that I'll even more
republicans are going to stay home this
year.
Then stayed home for Romney in 2012.
Let's not forget Gary Johnson to time
elected governor of New Mexico who was
only invited to I think two or three gop
debates and all of 2012 ran as,
as the Libertarian Party candidate got a
million votes.
Mark my words,
Dave Rubin,
Gary Johnson's going to get more than a
million votes this year and they're
terrified of more disaffected
Republicans staying home.
So the movement and the New York Times
wrote a whole piece about it is to get,
say,
a Rick Perry to run as a third party
knowing he'll never get it to fall on
his sword,
but their fear is that Donald Trump is
not just going to cost them the White
House.
They're writing that off there.
They're afraid of losing the Senate.
So if you can get a Rick Perry or an
attractive well known conservative to
run to at least get the social
conservatives out of the house so
they'll still vote and then vote are all
the way down tickets that could help
them save the Senate.
We shouldn't be saying this because I
want them to lose the Senate,
but it is a smart strategy.
God.
It's such intricate little moves and
machinations of the system and that
you're agreeing with the ideas of Bill
Kristol to sort of take down trump
be with the idea,
but I think it's a smart idea if they
want to keep the Senate
right.
So I liked that you brought out Gary
Johnson.
I've had Gary Johnson on the show.
I think he is an extremely decent human
being.
I've watched,
I think I was one of the two people that
watched the libertarian debates.
Um,
what's your line on Libertarians?
You've got a good line on Libertarians
and a bunch of lines and libertarian.
They're liberals with that,
uh,
something or.
No,
and I think libertarian is just Latin
for embarrassed Republican.
I like that.
That's my cat.
My cat just like,
like,
look,
I know you're too stupid to get.
We'd all just be more selfish.
Dick's,
oh look.
A food appeared magically before me and
I did nothing for it.
I met special and no one else had a role
in bringing my food to make you want the
nine rand book.
I've got nine more.
You know,
you know what?
I had the,
I had the president of the Iron Ran
Institute on last week.
You're going to have to watch the show.
Maybe I'll have you guys on together to
battle it out.
Yeah,
I mean look out Somalia doing.
The fact is even if a libertarian became
elected president,
which won't happen,
you are never.
First off,
you can believe in religion and science.
You don't get to claim you follow Ian
Rand and Jesus.
Okay.
And uh,
Ran Paul,
by the way,
ran away from libertarianism faster than
Ian Ran,
ran to the mailbox for her social
security check.
No president is ever going to want to be
the president who does away with social
security and Medicare and Medicaid and
the entire social safety net.
It's never gonna happen.
So those,
those types of things,
that would just be,
if you're a purist libertarian,
like every party,
there's ways of taking the sort of
ideals of libertarianism,
of limited government and freeing up
business more things like that,
um,
without necessarily destroying social
security and still allowing for some
safety net and things like that.
So it's.
Yeah,
yeah,
I mean,
you know,
we'll see.
I mean,
I'm,
I liked Dr Jill Stein and the Green
party as well.
Like I,
I would love to see at least one debate
where all the third party,
Major,
third party candidates have to be on the
stage with the big too.
Because what we're seeing here with both
Bernie and trump is a massive American
discontent with this.
A snake with two heads that's taken over
the whole game.
People don't trust the two party system
and believe me,
we're all going to be so sick of seeing
that picture of the trumps and the
Clintons at the wedding laughing
together because it's the ultimate
signal of just how there's,
there's us and there's them and most of
the Republicans and Democrats in this
country are part of the US.
Yeah.
Well that's also why I.
Yeah,
I had Gary Johnson on the show,
but I've tweeted several times and I've
tried to put the message out there that
even if you don't love this guy,
even if this isn't your guy,
if you guys get him to 15 percent,
once the general election is on,
they have to put him in the debate.
So it's probably not gonna happen for
Jill Stein because she's running what,
72 times already,
but Gary Johnson,
I think this year,
what
once course she's run
only only ones before.
Okay.
One 72,
whatever it is.
Um,
but Gary,
Joseph,
I do think there's such discontent that
there's a chance that at some point they
could just get them to 15 percent and
they'd have to throw another voice in
there.
So I'm not even making it about him as
much as just give us another voice.
Give us another option.
Someone let us here another idea.
Honestly,
if the,
if the DNC wasn't walking around in
clown shoes,
they would pour a lot of money into the
right to life parties because there's so
many social conservatives who only vote
for the Republican party because of the
abortion issue.
The Republican Party will never allow
abortion to become illegal.
It is their number one fundraising tool.
And Trust me,
as long as politicians have Mr Seuss,
abortion will remain legal in this
country.
Uh,
and I can talk about that issue all day
long,
but you know,
to me why more conservatives don't bail
on the Republican Party and go ahead and
vote right to light.
If you're already a single issue voter.
And by the way,
a grotesque hypocrite because Jesus out
against the death penalty never
mentioned abortion and got technically
beliefs,
prolife character in the Bible,
but that's a whole other matter to me.
You know,
the Bush family was never against
abortion rights,
never against the war.
And Donald Trump's not against,
of course,
you know,
they,
they put on this charade,
they shuffle it around.
And these social conservatives,
I mean,
Alabama keeps voting for these people
over and over and over again.
And nothing changes.
Howard Dean was really smart with the 50
state strategy when he ran the DNC.
And a smart,
charismatic Democrat would try to make
inroads down there.
Trust me,
if social conservatives who watch Fox
News could hear a Bernie Sanders speech
unedited,
they find themselves nodding every bit
as much as they do with trump,
only with Bernie.
It's policy with trump.
It's just personality.
So how much of this,
when we talk about the personality
thing,
that I really believe this election is
going to be one on the personality thing
and not on substance in any way.
Um,
how much of this is just the times we
live in,
it's just that we're all at twitter
expressing ourselves all the time.
It's all that everyone's on facebook
posting articles and fighting with
people in banning people in muting
people.
How much is just noise?
Do you have trouble?
I mean,
when you're doing your show,
even sort of separating the noise from
what's actually real.
Yeah,
but I think that's nothing new.
I mean,
you know,
look back to how vicious Jefferson Adams
were against each other in the press.
I mean,
Adams called out Jefferson for selling
his own children to slavery 200 years
ago.
You know,
Lincoln was so despised.
Roosevelt and eleanor were as hated as
the Clintons are.
All of this is really nothing new for
our country or our species.
And I think that,
you know,
the,
like George Carlin said,
when you're born you get a free ticket
to the free show.
Uh,
the trick is to not grow up enjoying the
freak show.
And so,
um,
you know,
yeah,
there's a lot of folks who are going to
have to patch up a lot of friendships
once this campaign is over and uh,
uh,
you know,
I appreciate my conservative and
progressive brothers and sisters who
were able to talk about this stuff like
grownups and not let hate getting the
way.
Yeah,
there's not many of us though,
or I guess there are,
but we're the silent majority.
That's what I said at the top of the
show that I think actually most people
don't feel like you have to have a
purity of political purity tests to be
friends with someone.
But there do seem to be sides that want
that to be.
And I think actually most people are
willing to do this and say,
all right,
if you go,
thanks at a couple of things that I
agree with and Ruben's at a couple of
things I agree with and,
and that's all right.
And that's the point.
I think you're right.
So,
uh,
we will,
we've only got a couple minutes left.
Who Do you think's doing it better than
us?
Is there a country that you look at
right now because you know,
Europe's got a whole slew of other
problems,
uh,
western Europe and Eastern Europe.
We,
there's all over the world.
There's,
everyone's got problems.
Is there any system that you could go
those guys that's the,
that's the way we should be doing it.
Well,
sure.
I mean it was a lot of people who are
doing the American dream has become the
Scandinavian dream and those are
capitalist societies with strong safety
nets where you pay higher taxes but you
get stuff for your taxes here.
We think we pay low taxes,
but we pay high for everything else.
Yeah,
you might pay lower taxes than our
European friends,
but then you're paying for your
healthcare.
You're paying for your senior care.
You're paying for your college loans for
the rest of your life.
Michael Moore's coming on my show today,
a year at Sirius Xm.
And uh,
I highly recommend his new film.
Nobody saw it.
It's called where to invade next.
And the idea of it is him going to
different countries and stealing.
They were good ideas and claiming it for
America because these other countries do
the American green better than we do.
There's still upward mobility in these
nations.
Uh,
Finland and Sweden.
Then of course,
Denmark,
which is considered the happiest country
in the world.
Um,
you know,
I,
I believe that America though,
I'm not going to abandon this country
for another one and I'm going to stick
around here and fight for decency and
love and common sense.
I was going to ask you another question,
but that's kind of a pretty decent way
to end the show,
Johnny.
Well,
thank you dave.
It's a pleasure to be here.
I hope it wasn't.
I'll bring lots of Dick Jokes next time.
Right?
Next time we'll,
we'll work blue,
uh,
and I look forward to coming on your
show again.
And you,
as I said at the top,
you are the one that drags me to stand
up.
I need to be doing more standup.
Dave,
you're really,
you're really good on stage.
You should be doing a lot more of it.
We need your voice out there,
uh,
in,
in the,
in the theaters as well as on the year.
Well,
that's exactly how I feel about you.
So I want to thank my guest,
John Bugle sang for joining me on the
show today.
You can hear more of John on,
tell me everything every Monday through
Friday from two to 5:00
PM eastern on Sirius Xm insight Channel
One 21.
Johnny,
thank you for doing this.
And next time we'll get the skype times
right and we'll work it all out and
you'll be in a fancy studio and you'll
look great and all that good stuff.
I appreciate it.
I'm also on the road touring across the
country right now.
I've just made my 21st out of state trip
in 2016 already.
Uh,
I want to thank you and the entire team
to put your show together.
I love what you do.
I love the show.
It's great to see what you're doing out
there.
And I think that you are an important
voice and I just want to give my respect
to everyone who works to make your show
happen.